what's up with it man it's the boy check
me out on the bullet cat podcast man
it's a lot of free game we giving y'all
boys man tune in it's just serious
podcast special guest in here the boy
repping the baby
welcome man i feel like i ain't seen you
since you were a part of the uh
the the legendary west coast collective
yeah we was at the radio station yeah i
know i did
yeah this was like in 27
17 or 18. one of them
i think this was prior to you guys
having any like real media training
because i did like an interview with
y'all once and it was like god-awful and
then the second go around it was a lot
better
i was like yeah why they even come up
here
you guys are just spaced out tired like
not saying [ __ ] yeah one word answers uh
no but yo man first of all congrats on
just like
you know a lot of people
in your situation might have had a hard
time like
you know i feel like the perceived it
guy in the group was young t.o
you guys broke up and sometimes when we
see groups break up man like it doesn't
go so well for everybody like
you know i think um phoenix flexing and
jesus are doing a great job after the
shoreline breakup and i think you you're
really like [ __ ] killing it right now
bro like what
like it seems like you just kind of came
out on the other side of the sob thing
like a lot stronger and like a lot more
just on your [ __ ]
yeah man i tried man i'm just trying to
keep this [ __ ] authentic you feel me
just keeping that [ __ ] fun yeah being
myself with this [ __ ] family that's all
um for people who don't know what the i
know i know what it stands for but i
can't say what it stands for well what
is the channel young wide [ __ ] okay
okay
or young wide nation however you want to
play i prefer the young wild nation you
know why nation yeah i keep it pg like
on some business [ __ ] you know what a
nation you got you gotta you gotta have
something caucasian friendly to get off
you know yes you know why nation for
sure it's like when the when amigos
first came out and it was like yrn and
i'm like i can't even like no it's young
rich nation i'm like no it's not oh
they're saying that
yeah you used to it's young rich nation
but it's really young rich
okay etceteras same [ __ ] yeah yeah mamas
um but yeah man i feel like you just
really been on youtube like uh the last
couple years has kind of taught you
about like your career and like where
you are like now
what it taught me
see
i ain't gonna lie [ __ ] had a lot of
downfalls in the beginning i embrace all
my downfalls for real like
i just try to defend me turn on my
negatives and the positives you feel me
instead a lot of [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] go through [ __ ] you feel
me that [ __ ] knocked their ass down it'd
be hard for them to get up you feel me i
just [ __ ] just have to get their ass
back up you feel me take this [ __ ] more
serious for a
long story short i get into detail if
you want me to yeah go ahead man [ __ ]
get into it that's what you're here for
uh i mean [ __ ] like what the group said
like y'all remember like when i first
started rapping i couldn't even really
rap like i was just saying anything like
you feeling me everything fast like i
mean saying anything like it was no
substance like you feeling me i'm just
talking [ __ ] like you was just running
your mouth yeah
i i was really just good for a verse you
feeling me like i wasn't the hook i
wouldn't know hook guy like you feeling
me
bro was doing all that he was taking
care of that [ __ ] like you feeling me
yeah that show on his back he's going
crazy like
he's making all the songs for real but
like
and they got to get older for real like
family [ __ ] learn how to
uh i started i started really training
myself to go to the studio more i was
never really know
i i wasn't in it i went in the gym like
that for like you were getting your reps
in hell nah like i was just a regular
[ __ ] doing regular [ __ ] you fam
but [ __ ] i be i ain't gonna lobby on
that type of time now like i love the
studio i don't want to do nothing but be
in that [ __ ] for real like i train
myself like
all right well i say i embrace all the
dumb [ __ ] that happened like
as in like
i embrace all the street [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] that you feel me i embrace
all the cutoffs
i embrace
i embrace like dropping all them weak
ass versus trying to find myself in the
studio um brady saw that [ __ ] so you
feeling me
all i all that [ __ ] did was just make me
wanna you feel me become a better me for
real
so
i i had to train myself like uh oh no i
wasn't when i was living in l.a i was i
wouldn't live in l.a i living in
glendale i was living in glendale but i
wasn't in my bag i went in my right bag
i moved to glendale
a little la area until you feel me stay
focused get away from home you feel me
what year was that
what was that i think
28
18 or 19. so this was like it is 20 18
19. this is like peak sob
like 2018 19.
i moved away to get focused and i wasn't
in the studio like that like you feel me
i'm sure i'm thugging with my [ __ ]
like as if i was home like i got [ __ ]
in l.a like you feel me i'm kicking it
with them [ __ ] like
just thugging i go to the studio every
now and then about what know that so i'm
like i could do this [ __ ] at home if i'm
be on this
after my son was born
oh no like [ __ ] i just
looked him in his eye one day and like
damn i gotta do this [ __ ] for real like
i just been going crazy ever since
[ __ ] just been in the studio like i
started freestyling and [ __ ] hella [ __ ]
but before i started freestyling
i had to start taking this [ __ ] most
serious i was taking this most serious
in the studio every day and it became
more and more easy to me and once i
started freestyling
it was way more fun to me like when i
was writing that she used to feel like
homework and [ __ ] like
me like it make a [ __ ] not even want to
be in the studio all night if no you got
a writing [ __ ] you feel me
once i got comfortable just going in
that [ __ ] and you found punching in
lying back launching in yeah i got way
more fun with this [ __ ] and it should
sound way better like you feel me a lot
of [ __ ] punch in and just you feel me
just trying to get the song done
quantity over quality my [ __ ] still
quality my [ __ ]
my other [ __ ] sound like quantity
compared to what i got now and i got and
i made way more songs
this year or whatever you feeling me
like
what i ever been making all the mirrors
like you found me [ __ ] comfortable in
the store and i embraced uh
i was on house arrest i got an album on
november 12th called house arrest coming
out that [ __ ] finna be hot harry
song owner i made that [ __ ] on house
arrest what was i going to say i embrace
that [ __ ] cause that
house being on house arrest that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] kept a [ __ ] focused for real
like i ain't gonna lie like that [ __ ]
had me on my program like i couldn't do
number go to the house and go to the
studio because that was my job you
feeling me so that's all [ __ ] doing so
as soon as i get off this [ __ ] i'm out
that business i'll probably get when i
get up like
a month and a half or something
yeah i probably got off like a month and
a half ago like my program instead of
saying like i'm on house arrest like i
go to the studio and i go home like you
feeling me like i feel it like like then
so you're still kind of on that routine
even though i'm still on that routine
that should be psyching me out sometimes
like damn like i can't go because
like this is really what i want to do
all day like if it's a it's a good
feeling no
um so you would say like that the
difference between you now and maybe a
couple years ago was like do you think
like you weren't maybe taking your craft
seriously yeah no i wouldn't because
[ __ ] like if i was taking a crab
serious back then like we would we would
have had way more classic [ __ ] like you
feel me i would have been more of an
aspect to the situation i was a good
aspect to the situation but i'd have
been a bigger aspect if i was taking the
most serious like yeah i was good but i
went great like you feel me like i'm in
the process of becoming great right now
is there old sob [ __ ] that you hear
yourself on you're like man that [ __ ]
was wack like [ __ ] i wish all the time
what's your least favorite verse and a
lot of them a lot of them yeah
i got i got some good ones though for
sure no no for sure but i just feel like
oh so there's a lot of [ __ ] out
there to me that's fair i mean it's also
dope to admit you know a lot of people
would admit such things you know what
i'm saying yeah i'm i'm my biggest
critic like
i go to this day like i could go in the
studio someone come out be like this
[ __ ] we like go to the next one like you
feel me so if i make some weak [ __ ] all
that [ __ ] is gonna make me wanna do is
just make something better like you
feeling me
i'm my biggest critic though for sure
like i ain't scared to
save my [ __ ] weak like
i ain't putting that [ __ ] out if i think
it's weak too like it's hella songs and
they can make that you feel me that
we'll never hear yeah we'll never hear
that's fair i can keep the quality
coming off a show with house arrest um
you know what's crazy is like i feel
like we kind of were all on house arrest
during the pandemic and i feel like it
kind of for the people who really
were hustlers or really had it in them
and not on them like it i made more
money during the pandemic than i've ever
had in my life and not not off of ppp
loans are so all right legitimately but
um
i feel like there's something about that
where like it just kind of activates you
like something in your brain where it's
like hey
activate like a different type of
hustlers yeah not facts bro who else on
the album
see i got
i got omb peasy i got all black
i got rimble
kyla shanae yeah i got cash key
oh you got a lineup on there shout out
to rumble man cool little starting five
shout out to him you're going crazy
right now yeah rumble's a fan of that
man he's uh
he's different he's different different
he kind of took what draco does but like
does his own thing like kind of a spawn
of draco but like he's different though
he just talks very calmly on beats hey
like a scholar yeah it's like he's
teaching like college courses yeah like
oh
that's how you go crazy in the game like
you got to approach the stop you gotta
approach this [ __ ] like with a style of
your own you can't just approach it with
something different though i to be
different and unique that [ __ ] [ __ ]
different and unique so you feel me it's
only right keep going crazy no 100 um
do you have any sort of relationship
with anybody from sob anymore
slim
okay
that's good i just feel like y'all are
one of the biggest what-ifs like ever
i i don't know what it is man about the
west coast and not being able to keep
[ __ ] groups together like short-lived
mafia after y'all came after you and it
was like
damn what if like two more years
[ __ ] could have really i remember like
going to seeing you guys i was in
seattle and [ __ ] was october of 2018 and
you guys had a show in seattle viral and
i was like yo this these guys have got
something special going here seattle
love us i love seattle yeah no it was
crazy but like do you ever like think
back like
man what if we would have just all
been on the same page the kind of run
you guys could have had are you happy
with
where your journey has led you we would
have surely been going crazy but like it
was a lot of [ __ ] going on like
i feel everybody probably happier like
how [ __ ] is right now like i'm happy i
know slimy happy
i'm pretty sure everybody else happy
like you feeling me we all happy like
you feminists
like
everybody uh was i gonna say like
uh
to me for me i'm gonna speak for myself
like i feel more refreshing like you fam
there's a lot of [ __ ] i ain't gotta deal
with you feeling me
[ __ ] more refreshing i can focus you
feeling me worry about me you only have
yeah well now you have to only worry
about what you want and
now you could tell your story without
having to worry about you know i feel
like that's the one thing about being in
a group it's like there's always a
compromise with the creativity you know
one [ __ ] could say some stupid ass [ __ ]
and like you feeling me everybody name
tied to it like you finn
i'm
refreshing like i'm good like
i used to be stressed out like hell and
[ __ ] like [ __ ] i stressed out like no
nothing like i'm good like
i want to ask you this because i always
uh when when
i feel like you guys had a lot of
influence
on a lot of people that you guys don't
get credit for yeah at all like when
blueface first started popping
i remember like when we interviewed
blueface i was like
i brought you all up because i was like
well it's not like he's the first guy to
kind of i [ __ ] a blue face no and
blueface is the homie and i think
blueface is dope as [ __ ] but i felt like
when i heard like a guy like blueface i
was like i hear like the influence of
of what you guys were doing like you
guys feel like you don't get enough
props i'm not even talking about
specifically with him i'm gonna lie like
i seen an interview
with blueface he was like
oh somebody asked him about do we listen
to like [ __ ] in the bay
he was like nah nah he's like nah not
really but i [ __ ] with s.o.b rb though
like that makes sense
like i ain't saying you got a style from
it's like oh
like [ __ ]
like it's like you guys you guys
definitely we created a lot of people we
influenced so many people like you never
know where [ __ ] got that sound
from so it's really [ __ ] that
you feel me get that sound from
somewhere else that you send me a
[ __ ] got it from somewhere else
or somewhere else or somewhere else even
subconsciously people don't even realize
the [ __ ] they're influenced by yeah like
[ __ ] don't a lot of
[ __ ] don't be hip-hop [ __ ] but
like that [ __ ] happens with the bae all
the time though i feel like everybody's
influenced by the band i'm not we don't
blueprint around this [ __ ] for a show
but like a lot of [ __ ] don't
know that because the sound like we made
it universal everybody copying each
other like don't nobody know like where
is where [ __ ] coming from would you say
like was your and like sobs influences
like coming up because at the time when
you guys are coming up that's probably
right around the time like hbk gang
started to kind of cool off and like
kind of go their own way i used to
listen to hbk game middle school was so
heavy i used to love them boys then
they're like beginning of high school
too
what i gonna say
our influence is like our main
influences was really like
nwa
you feel me just coming out rowdy
rapping on like them old school beats
and [ __ ]
like detroit was a part of that [ __ ] too
like yeah there's something about
detroit in the bay that's like they're
like married to each other somehow yeah
like all my [ __ ] was listening that's
all they listened to was detroit [ __ ]
like to this day like my [ __ ] love
detroit music like you finn
so uh the bay loves detroit and the game
loves the bay i'm around these [ __ ]
like you feel me you uh you are all you
hang around so i'm eventually i start
loving that [ __ ] too like you family a
lot of the i mean [ __ ] the same temple
on a lot of records i had buffs in like
2014 like you feeling me like before i
was rapping like we was already on that
like
uh
and we all i guess that [ __ ] just all
came together and we just put that [ __ ]
in one like
but [ __ ] we really wanted to the only
the only thing [ __ ] really took from
detroit though i give them
[ __ ] took the uh the glasses though i
ain't gonna lie like
that [ __ ] slimy like he used to show me
he used to slap hella detroit [ __ ] and
autumn i used to love them glasses i
just blow them [ __ ] dope with them
call you family soon as he told me i had
them [ __ ] i never took them [ __ ]
off you found me i love them [ __ ]
to this day i still i don't wear them
[ __ ] like that i got i got something
but like only like wearing them [ __ ]
like
if i get something it's going i might
get clear lens or something like you
feel me
look like an intellectual around this
[ __ ] like i ain't trying to be looking
like rumble
looking like how rebel sounds
[ __ ]
hey what up man we gotta interrupt the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at odd socks now when i be
riding for odd socks so hard man it's
because i really love the product they
got the most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world i got a pair of odd socks
basics on right now go get those they
got the socks wwe joints you know i'm
saying shout out to the undertaker pepsi
[ __ ] really whatever you need
some weed socks nickelodeon but really
they got the draws now ladies and
gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapateo underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick pop
tart draws and these [ __ ] are
so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev at
oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20 off
underwear the most comfortable socks in
the world crazy licenses not only they
got the ww they got the scarface they
got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview um what what part of the baby
from i'm from valley shout out to
vallejo we just had the russell up here
who's doing this thing everybody going
crazy he's [ __ ] wrestling i feel like
vallejo is like uh
man we were talking we were talking a
little and we train setters for sure we
trend setters and we ain't getting no
flowers around this [ __ ] but i mean
[ __ ] it's all good we're just gonna take
over this [ __ ] and they're gonna see
you later is it frustrating like for
people who aren't from the bay how they
just box everything into like oh you're
from san francisco
and ain't frustrating but like i i know
how everybody think i i got that
understood that's how they gonna think
but like earlier when you got here you
were like l.a i mean glendale hey cause
it's not the same thing but alright
like i got some [ __ ] from
i got some [ __ ] from l.a like you
famous i already know it's kind of like
the same thing when people think of the
bay they think of like san francisco and
they just box it all in and it's like no
san francisco is a city yeah
totally different than glendale totally
yeah totally different thing so i had to
correct myself i don't know so
so what i'm living in
what is it about vallejo you think that
like
had
has produced so much historical talent
and like
like you said i do feel like there's a
lot of transcending that comes out of
vallejo i mean chill out like i said
like we trendsetters like
we got boys that grew up like we got
legends from out there
we got mac dre
like you feeling me big legend like
whole world know about ain't got 840
we gotta be legit
what's we got cece sabathia like we got
hella [ __ ] shout out to the
yankees yeah like we got legends around
that [ __ ] like
yourself uh nothing left to fail from
there yeah and that the pharaoh uh all
them [ __ ] and like thing about us like
we like to be different too
like you think we don't like to see what
a [ __ ] doing and then like try to sound
like a [ __ ] no none of that we all like
to be different stand out
what is like if you're from vallejo
coming up what did you what which
football team does vallejo usually
choose we know e40 is a niner fan
is it the raiders or is it the niners
obviously now the raiders are from vegas
i ain't gonna lie my parents from
oakland so they went for the writers so
that's what i grew up with ruling folk
but like
people around me like growing up like
[ __ ] i met growing up in a v
like
yeah i think i think [ __ ]
really be going for the night maybe it'd
be 50 50. yeah there's niners right
there's a lot of niner fans though
um is the bippin thing like as big of a
deal in vallejo as it is like in san
francisco not as big but you'll get your
ass bipped out there though cuz that
[ __ ] is crazy and it's big i heard like
right now that they have like a hundred
thousand dollar reward if you if you
could turn someone in who
is doing that [ __ ] hell yeah i seen that
[ __ ] i don't think that [ __ ] true though
i mean [ __ ] it might i see it on the
news or something i'm just sitting on
like a blog site like it's a meme like
is it real yeah like that type [ __ ] like
because i might turn myself in for
bitman if i'm gonna
it might be worth doing a few months in
jail for a hundred bands you know what
i'm saying
that [ __ ] playing no that shit's crazy
and then i saw like uh my wifey hold it
down till you get out yeah like we got
100k we're going to chill 90 days you
know don't bail me out keep all that i'm
going to steal this ipad from myself
you know the bitman [ __ ] in san
francisco is insane like it's hell yeah
i know uh uh burner's putting out like a
he's putting out a movie
that kind of is all about that [ __ ] like
a like a hood like paid in fools like
these [ __ ] these [ __ ] that come up
hundreds of bands off that [ __ ] like
yeah actually it's crazy i don't need
one given i don't wanna get no free game
on that but yeah you get your ass bit
yeah cause it's almost like it's almost
like like the lotto right like you just
hit as many cars and like hope that one
of them has someone someone slipping a
lotto for sure
and then there's so much like there's so
much weed money coming in and out of san
francisco a lot of those dispensaries is
all cash it's like
i don't know
that's crazy um what what's
you know when we're talking about this
album uh house arrest what
what was like the most challenging
part about making this project for you
challenging
um i ain't gone the only challenging
part i had with this project was picking
out my songs because you had so many
that [ __ ] was done before but i had
everybody listen to it that's like [ __ ]
you gotta start doing features like he
ain't got no features like
actually made me realize like okay
features really do matter like because
this is a [ __ ] that it's a [ __ ]
i'll listen to your tape just because
they favor rapper on that [ __ ] like you
that's some real [ __ ] bro and if that
[ __ ] sounded good like you feel me they
might [ __ ] around
album yeah
oh mama's like features is important
like from now i'm doing all features if
i do
a tape or no features it might be like
something small like a little ep or
something like i
now i only like listening to [ __ ]
types of things got no features unless
they like really one of them boys but
like
you gotta have features like
i see that [ __ ] now it's very rare to
see a project with no features too like
j cole does it i know keegalock just uh
put it out [ __ ] dude album comes out
tonight and then there's zero features
he he dropped the trackless he like
and he like it was like i'm revealing my
features and it was it was just nobody
else for keeglock featuring keyclock
that's what it's saying no i mean no but
it's pretty much
pretty much the case yeah i say that did
you have to pay for any of your features
on this album and uh everybody did for
the love yeah little swap yeah i ain't
never paid for the future
i'll pay for a feature though the right
one yeah the right one is always worth
it but like i pay for the future so was
there anyone you tried to like tap in
with it it just didn't end up working
out
i mean [ __ ] like not nobody that replied
back for real like i probably hit a
[ __ ] trying to work like you
know how that [ __ ] be like when a
[ __ ] booming like i ain't gonna
see or dm for real like your family
[ __ ] got emotion like them [ __ ]
wash up yeah hey
and they also like you're you're like if
if you're that big you get so many
and i ain't even as big as you feel me a
[ __ ] i'm trying to work with you
so i can only imagine who who are your
favorite artists right now that you're
like a fan of that you're really [ __ ]
with
uh i [ __ ] i [ __ ] with dirk
i [ __ ] with yes tg
i [ __ ] a little baby
i [ __ ] with uh
i [ __ ] with [ __ ] two that [ __ ] hard
yeah he's crazy uh let me see
i [ __ ] i [ __ ] with that [ __ ] babyface
toe
baby i [ __ ] with i [ __ ] with everybody
in the bay too like they going crazy
like
i listen and [ __ ] that's one thing about
me like i ain't late on nothing like who
out of the bay like can you
that you know you think it's kind of
like representing the area well right
now that's
newer
right now
right now my little brother out there
going crazy and [ __ ] cato he got a song
called go off that [ __ ] like
viral tic toc that [ __ ] slap too
i look that [ __ ] up
like
uh it's here i can lie whole bait going
crazy like whole san francisco like
his [ __ ] in oakland going crazy
right now like
we got a little emotion in the v like
you feeling me it's something
stockton ain't the babe but like you
family it's it's acting it's not
all
it's going crazy right now stockton
going crazy so why i drove through
stockton i drove through stockton last
month with my boy who's from there
i was like damn this [ __ ] is this is
this this ain't this ain't no place to
play around with here hey
it's trenches for sure yeah i'm like who
would have thought it's just i just
think of stockton i don't know why i
mean i've never been there i just always
think of like some small little town you
know what i'm saying and it's trenches
over there so and then you hear some of
these artists out of there that [ __ ]
they're like damn stockton that crazy
yeah i ain't never really been out there
like that for real but like you've never
had a show in stockton
uh i feel like that hadn't happened
right now probably especially with sob
if we did it was probably like one time
but like i ain't never like i ain't
never been to like no hood or none over
there like dave's hot chicken touchdown
i probably went to like yeah dave's hot
chicken going crazy i probably went to
like a
auntie house or something back in the
day when i was little but i ain't never
seen like they hoods or none of that
[ __ ] like i know his transfers out there
though so i just ain't got no business
out there um what would it take for you
and the other guys from sob to ever do
like a reunion project
or is that has there been so much [ __ ]
said to where it's like no coming back
from at this point
no i think that should have happened
again
yeah i don't know about that one i mean
if that [ __ ] happened [ __ ] we must be
dead
wow that's what it is where somebody
else put that [ __ ] without everybody
permission type [ __ ] like you feel me
what what about you and slimy would you
guys do like an offshoot of like
since you're still tight with him like
we just got to take
we got we got to take on still ganging
like a couple months ago i think it's
september
was that uh
received well from like the og fans
you said it was a receiver yeah like did
like like like did that because you know
i feel like a lot of a lot of you guys
fans were so [ __ ] crazy and diehard
yeah i was [ __ ] with that [ __ ] but a
lot of [ __ ] you know how they
want they want the whole group but like
you feel me that's only the beginning
like you feel them
and worry about it like we got
we got [ __ ] on the way like this should
only get better and better
hey there it is man shout out to vallejo
vallejo's finest in the building um so
look november 12th the album is out
november 12th house
yes sir love the name yes sir how many
songs all together you sitting on right
now i don't even know i
sometimes i look at my email and just go
through and i'll be like damn i forgot
about this [ __ ] like i got a hell of
[ __ ] like
and i could put 10 tapes together right
now if i want to but like
you know how that should be i'm only
pick out the quality like you feel me a
lot of [ __ ] like the sounds sound kind
of old like you feel me like
i keep the crispiest ones around though
like i don't lose them [ __ ] like
a lot of songs if if i forgot about it
like he ain't one of the ones then but
like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] like cool to keep in the
archives for like you feeling me for the
future
like [ __ ] might create album i
might create albums and [ __ ]
might create albums and [ __ ] from my son
and [ __ ] with a [ __ ] not here and see
fam that's some real [ __ ] make some
cheese out that [ __ ] man it's some [ __ ]
gonna be left back for a show i just had
a homie who uh he's got like a little
following and he put out uh
he took all those songs that like he'll
never put out and he put him on an album
that
um
fans could it would never be on dsps
so he sold him for a hundred dollars it
was like 30 records on a cd or on a usb
drive see i i know some others and he
sold like a thousand he sold a thousand
of them so he hit like a hundred
thousand dollar lick like that and
almost selling [ __ ] that he never
planned on taking out like putting out
and then it's never gonna be on dsps
that's the way to do it for so and i and
i got some [ __ ] that i ain't never gonna
put out that still hot but it's like
i'm
uh what the [ __ ] i'm put i'm putting the
hottest out i still got some hot [ __ ]
out but i'm putting the hottest out so
i'm gonna [ __ ] around do that cd [ __ ]
for for sure man well listen we
appreciate you pulling up uh the album
is out on what next friday right
november 12th i don't know what's the
next friday what's today's the six
oh yeah so next friday next friday
thursday 9 pm pst midnight est man let's
go get the album shout out to the boy
appreciate you pulling up shout out
vallejo man yeah sir shout out to thank
you for having me yes sir